thank you thank you everybody yeah hi
I'm Mary Poppins and this is rich Wow I
I couldn't have predicted this Here I am
doing the monologue in the rain I put a
man a John Cusack movie this is okay so
like I have to tell you things are
getting very weird very weird I was out
driving in LA this week not going
anywhere you know did you get go
anywhere but just had to get out of the
house and I tell you it's a little Airy
out there it's like a movie where all
human life has been wiped out except for
the gardener's
[Applause]
and and I noticed that the gas prices
their advertising way low like one was
like under $1 just like that dangling an
offer we can't take advantage up it's
like when the wife says I was horny last
night but you were asleep my right my
right guys am i right audience
great crowd what a crowd tonight but no
la I tell you it's it's a weird thing
here I mean I've known people in this
town who who like locked themselves
inside for three weeks but it was always
because they got a nose job and last
week I'm like Rodney Dangerfield like
last week I tell you I was lonely I had
a home invader I said look you're
already here stay for dinner I mean what
else can you do I tried to start new
hobbies you know I I'm doing a lot of
baking some days as soon as I wake
[Applause]
but I don't know what else to do with my
time I I you know I'm home I I waste a
lot of time on the internet I I binge
watch TV I have food delivered
oh god I'm becoming a millennial piece
now I see why they're so depressed oh
and they are pretty depressed this week
this was a rough week for the
Millennials Bernie Sanders I'm sure you
heard dropped out of the race and his
supporters are taking it very hard they
did not expect Bernie to quit they say
it just proves that he is part of the
conspiracy against Bernie Sanders
[Applause]
Oh an older crowd yeah so so joe biden's
the man that's right the fate of the
earth rests on Joe Biden the forces of
light will be represented by mr. Joe
Biden or as the Jedi call him Obi one
where am I
yeah Jeff buckets doing these video
updates from his basement it's not
encouraging one was just him down there
for 45 seconds going what did I come
down here for
meanwhile Trump of course does these
daily briefings for like 90 minutes and
I got to give it to this guy he will
stay up there until it is clear that he
is absolutely no idea what he's talking
about he's like the toddler in the car
with the plastic steering wheel who
thinks he's driving
and drum I love this no masks he says he
doesn't see himself wearing a mask
no either
now he will not wear a mask he says
there's enough worth putting on my face
but but we have to that's it you know in
LA we have to wear a mask ma'am oh yeah
that's it that's required that's not a
request anymore you have to wear a mask
if you go out and get this in New York
the Health Department says they strongly
recommend masturbation instead of actual
sex we're not just gonna flatten the
curve we're gonna spank it
I'm good it's letting up and finally we
want to give good wishes to Boris
Johnson that's right he is one of the
people who we know has the coronavirus
but he's out of the ec ICU and he's
doing better there in Great Britain but
until he returns to work Great Britain
is without a leader join the club
you